nicole and i have problems right now
we thought a couple of times about
surgery so
i'm working on that but at the other day
i love nicole i really
like her i really love her and i really
want to be with her so
i decided to go to see pedro
you bring my sister here in the middle
of the pandemic
that was a big mistake over there so
like do i what it was a big mistake if
you don't read the news he said you know
what happened while you bring my sister
here and put her in the dangerous
situation nicole asked her mother
can i come to new york no no no nbc
alejandro and your mother tell nicole
it's all right if he pay for the ticket
it's all right after she came
she was mad at nicole that's not my
problem
and she was safe here with me
i came to this invitation to this
meeting with the best intention
that i
could had for him
i also bought a gift for him but he
didn't even have a spark of decency to
open the gift like that was very
disrespectful and insulting cheers
cheers man
[ __ ] for your boy bro
you take my sister over my mom he let my
mom over there by herself
um nicole is a grown woman
who knows what is good or bad for her um
i don't even care
what your mother thinks about that what
you think about that my only priority
here my only responsibility is to make
nicoles happy
if you don't like it if your mother will
like it i don't give a
i don't even care what pedro or lydia
think about
my business or my relationship with
nicole because my prayer is her
happiness and that's the only thing that
matters in here
but they didn't they don't care about
that they just care about themselves
when i went to america republic wow your
mind was very disrespectful what are you
thinking you're doing bro
wait well first first first first first
you are married and you you get the name
of your problem that's gonna make your
business no that's my problem stay in
your lane no yeah probably because if
that's why you're gonna use it it's on
the rocks better than you you know why
is it better than you because you're
better than jokes better than yours okay
man you don't know anything about my
wife you don't know anything about my
relationship you know everything about
me and you're you're criticizing me
judging me and you he's perishing me why
are you saying that nothing about that
i'm a [ __ ] business because my
sister's with you don't say what i'm
doing
walk away and letting you do whatever
you want to do to my sister hell no bro
what the hell what are you talking about
your opinion is here
i just here for your system i'm not here
for you for my sister
you are in your mouth
[Music]
you